Hello, welcome to another Zoom call and we're going to jump right into it.
Please do know that I should update this again that we had issues with our YouTube channel
you to completely de-platform us, but then we got that back on.
Like before that, we were hacked by somebody who was crazy.
We had all these videos on Bitcoin or something like that.
From some major ginormous company way bigger than us, so they were at the ones that hacked us.
So we got finally our channel reinstated, but we do have, we're putting all our Zoom calls up on our new video sites.
So go to our videos.colourstudic.com and you'll see links all over our website for that in our member site.
So please do look for the Zoom calls there and you'll search for Zoom calls in the date and you'll find it.
So we're moving more and more away from having any use in YouTube at all.
Remember, you can self-schedule any calls you need with me on our sites as well.
Let's jump into the calls.
Hello, Mike.
So Mike is this person.
Spouse had a grade four astrocytoma removed almost two years ago.
Several months ago his brain scan started to change and they just scheduled him for surgery next week.
Does he need to change or stop any supplements prior to surgery?
So yes, so if you're going to do surgery, you don't want to take any supplements with anti-quagulators that are anti-quagulating type supplements.
So anything really with garlic in them, anything with even obegas I would say don't do what you're going to do.
But the most important one to stay away from is is garlic.
Garlic is going to be, you know, the one that's going to thin your blood, the most and it's going to cause difficulty in clotting.
And you don't want there to be any difficulty in clotting with the surgeons doing surgery or post-surgical.
You want to make sure that you're clotting and you're forming.
You get fibrillated and laid out and you're getting healing.
So that's the biggest thing that you would do prior to surgery.
So will any of his supplements interact with anything that he's given with surgery?
Vitamin C is the only thing that he said he's going to be on.
Well, I don't know that so they're the unknown is, you know, you're going to be given, you know, some type of drug to knock you off for the surgery.
And literally there's just no known interactions with those types of drugs and no idea what they're going to use.
Then there's no known interactions with that. So you're just safe to like two days, maybe three days before the surgery just go off of everything and don't start any of the supplements back up until a few days later.
We know that there's proper healing and blood clotting and you don't have any beliefs or anything like that that you can go back on stuff.
Even at that, if you were taking a garlic pill, like, you know, there might be garlic in like glutamate scavenger or something like that that you're taking, but not enough to be an issue multiple days after the surgery.
But if I was two, three, four days out from the surgery, I still would go on a straight garlic pill because you don't want, you still want to make sure that you're not going to end up with any beliefs.
So, safe wise, I would just go off a few days before and just stay off of it for a few days afterwards.
Okay, I'm the one that wrote about the painkriotic enzymes last Wednesday.
So if you did listen to last Wednesday's call, somebody asked about painkriotic pork enzymes and what that was.
And I explained it briefly, but I didn't wait to our website and so remember, remember, remember, if you are looking for anything, do go to our blog and search for it.
So there's lots of information on our blog about painkriotic enzymes and enzyme therapy and enzyme therapy with cancer and painkriotic pork enzymes and Dr. Gonzalez and things like that.
Right, heavily about that in our book to have multiple videos about that as well.
I need to tell you that you determined my cancer as to not eat any pork, so pork and dairy were, were something that I limited this person for for their cancer.
You also said you test for that meeting the painkriotic enzymes and you didn't recommend enzyme therapy as something that I would need, but I was wondering if the benefits would outweigh any risks having pork in my system.
So understand, if you're having painkriotic pork enzymes, that's not like eating pork.
So those are, it's just sourced from pork. It's still just that specific enzyme. It's not, it's not pork. So it's not going to feed your cancer.
So let's say you're on a pork free diet. Should you not take pork enzymes, enzymes that are sourced from pork. The answer is my opinion, no, you can take that. There's no harm at taking that.
Would you eat, you know, pork desiccated pork liver if you're on a pork free diet. Still no, that's not an issue. Now if you're stayed off of pork for religious reasons like your Jewish or Muslim, and is there a harm in taking pork enzymes?
No, it's still not pork.
So I don't, you're going to have to decide if you're a rabbi about that, but there's, it's not, there's not pork in pork enzymes. So you should say, but take you.
Besides the fact that there's lots of enzymes that aren't sourced from pork. So as I stated last week, it's the only ones that we have that are sourced from pork and from pork.
Are that allergy, research, brand, pancreatic, pork, enzyme, product? All our other ones are not sourced from pork.
So taking digestime plus taking our pancreas, eight X or 10 X, 10 X ultra, we have tons of different enzymes on our store.
That effect for a patient a couple of weeks ago, begging that I divided it out costs per, per, you know, dosage, and they're all pretty much equal.
So making one of those enzymes, if you're concerned about pork, and for religious reasons, it's just fine.
I recently heard that fed medizol may work better if you take it with some fats or after eating fatty foods, is this true? What would be your recommendation?
Well, interesting. I have not heard that. However, I will say that there are many things that do work better that if they're emulsified in fats. So it's not just fed medizol. Some drugs work better, but they're emulsified a bit of fat.
So that taking them with fatty foods, you could get better absorption with it. So I haven't heard that about panventizol, but that may be true.
And if that is true, I don't think there's anything wrong with doing that. So I would just I would go for that. I don't do some research on that. So have you had a chance to read the article on the Randall cycle and cortisol that I emailed you.
If so, wondering if you agree or disagree with Mercola's change of mind regarding long term low carb diets and unrestricted eating since I've experienced recent minor weight gain that seems to be explained by my high fat intake while failing to lower carb intake enough.
I would climb to correct course by reverting back to my initial higher carb lower fat approach. So I did get to read Dr. Mercola's article and watch this video. And that's what he's advocating is that some people need to go back to a higher carb low fat approach.
And I'll tell you my opinion about it in a second. I also want to enhance my body's production of an 80 plus by taking his recommended 50 milligram dose of diacinamide three times per day. I'm curious on how this might interplay with my high holocysteine levels that I manage by supplementing with B. I currently take premier research complete B.
Serving sizes two caps I'm taking three that appears the dosage of what's on there since I'm getting 37.5 milligrams diacinamide here. Maybe I only need two doses of the 50 milligrams.
So what do I think about his approach? So, so honest opinion, I think that changing one's diet. So everything you got to understand everything he said in that information is not rotating to cancer patients.
But I remember literally everything you read you have to read through the lens of what it does for cancer patient versus what it does for a non cancer patient. So that being said his approach what he was recommended is that he tends to be fairly dogmatic.
It is approach that that he's switching back to a high carb low fat diet and he recommends simple carbs, not complex carbs.
Now I see that that can be good for some people at different times. I think rotating your diet can be helpful.
So in that sense, I would agree with him. But to advocate a high carb low fat diet for people I think is can be extremely dangerous.
First of all, I think the worst diets that were ever created and caused more ill help long term, not only to the person, but to the children of these people, especially if it was a female, because this this type of diet was really prominent in the 60s and 70s and even into the 80s was a low fat diet.
And all these products came out that were low fat low and fat. You still see them on the shelf these low fat products. I think that is the most detrimental all your cell membranes are our possible lipid bilayers, meaning they are made from fats, your brain cells are made from fats.
And we saw horrible detrimental effects to low fat diets back in the 80s when I was practicing back that of the 80s and actually into the 90s to
and what little child who was two years old still could not even sit up at two years old. And that is actually named a syndrome called floppy baby syndrome. Yes, that was the name of it floppy baby syndrome.
And it was caused from what not enough fat of the diet the mother was on a low fat diet all the way through the pregnancy. And if she was breastfeeding on a low fat diet, she kept a child with a low fat diet once they were eating food.
I remember having this baby who couldn't sit up was floppy down all we did is start that baby on a liquid omega three and within two weeks, they were sitting up and within I don't know several months, they were standing up against the table and they're walking around the table in saying how bad it is to go on a low fat diet. So for him to come up with it, it was just really strange watching him understand that but I do understand that I just wish he would have said this a few more times that this could be
this should be if you're going to do this, it should be short term and it's not for everybody. And then he was advocating simple carbohydrates and he gave some reasons for simple carbohydrate use.
All these things that he said were would be in my mind dangerous to a cancer patient simple carbohydrate use you got glucose, the cancer patient is burning glucose through glycolysis, you're kicking out two ATPs.
And if you have plenty of simple carbohydrates to burn, the cancer patient will actually that cancer cell will even be further trained to feed mainly off of glycolysis and the low oxidative form and feed it off of black tape.
So I think that would be a very dangerous approach for cancer. Furthermore, he went on to talk about NAD and the importance of NAD and stimulating NAD NAD plus NADH through using niacinamide.
Now I think a healthy dose of niacinamide, which you're going to find in your B vitamins is going to be just fine.
But when you're increasing NAD, it has multiple problems. So NAD increases the recycling of glutathione and for a non cancer patient, that's great because we are experiencing way too much oxidative stress.
Remember, poisons, oxidizing agents, reactive oxygen species, can damage cells, can damage cell membranes, can damage nucleus of cell and can cause cancer and cause mitochondrial damage, et cetera, et cetera.
And that can cause cancer, but a person with cancer, a cancer cell, because it's in rapid replication does not have perfectly for mitochondria.
Therefore, it does not produce adequate amounts of glutathione, because it's in rapid replication.
And therefore, it's more susceptible to reactive oxygen species, aka oxidizing agents, and will be killed by oxidizing agents.
And it might not always a good idea to stimulate the decreasing amount to stimulate the death of, or the oxidation, the death of reactive oxygen species in a cancer patient.
Right? Question, a couple of weeks ago, should all cancer patients be on booze? I only answer is no. They shouldn't be on booze, or should they be on things that are going to stimulate that, that every cancer patient should, because reactive oxygen species can kill cancer patients, cancer cells.
So you can actually keep a cancer alive by doing that. So you have to be careful with that. I'm not saying you this, whoever asks this question shouldn't be on that.
I'm not saying that every cancer patient should limit NAD, NADH, glutathione, glutathione precursors, I'm not saying they should, but I'm just saying that you can't take
a piece of information that will be good for the general public and automatically apply it to someone who has a history of cancer or has active cancer.
Because many times what is good for, especially when you talk about what's good for somebody with with coronary disease, the opposite is true for cancer.
Things that will stimulate nitric oxide and nitric oxide synthase for coronary patient shouldn't be used with the cancer patient because they're going to, it's going to stimulate an ethereal growth factor.
And so you just got to be careful equating those two. I don't say that's necessarily bad. I'm just saying that you just have to be careful equating there.
And as far as diet goes, you certainly don't want to be beating your cancer.
As a cancer patient, I would be far less concerned with increasing, oh, I've gained 10 pounds and I don't feel as healthy than I would by having my cancer stroke growth.
So, you know, somebody asked a question a few months ago as I'm 10 pounds, I'm about 10 pounds overweight.
What can I do to get rid of this weight? Honestly, as a cancer patient, that would be my least concern is have been a little bit overweight. My most concern is how do I keep this cancer from stop growing.
So, you don't want to be doing things that could potentially be the cancer and potentially negate effects of cancer killing properties in your body.
So, back to the NADH, glutathione issue, any any chemotherapy is an oxidizing agent, any chemotherapy is doing exactly the opposite of what Dr. McColo was represented in this video.
So, certainly if your person is on chemotherapy, you don't want to be doing this approach for sure.
Long winded approach, I think I have a bunch of information on the website about this too.
I get a burning sensation sometimes where I had radiation after my lack of breast mastectomy nearly four years ago, what would be the cause of this and how could I prevent it?
Well, nobody knows for sure, but you can speculate where you had radiation, there's cell damage.
This is why I'm not a big fan of radiating soft tissue because you could damage cells that can end up leading to cancer in the future at that spot.
So, you know, what can you so, but also there could be something like that going on, that would be the worst case scenario as a cancer growing at that spot.
Let's not go to that pathway too quickly though, so what are some other options that could be going, it could be just scar tissue, that's possibility.
So, there's a lot of different possibilities there, you could, what could you do to prevent it? Well, we don't know what the cause of that is.
So, it's certainly be ready, you're right. That's your best bet for this to assume, you know, the worst maybe so that you're going to treat them at the worst.
If it's just scar tissue, it's just your body healing, there's nothing you need to do, no concerns whatsoever.
If there is some cancer cell growth, which remember, you were never without cancer, so you're always treated as if anyhow.
So, make sure you're running the right, put the bomb right over that for a while, and you could tolerate it if it's not right in your eyes, try that.
So, you're just getting just some real direct hints of those frequencies on that, those are the kind of things I would do.
I know vitamin D is extremely important, especially for cancer patients, I've supplemented for years, but I can never see big of my levels up to where they should be even in the summer when I spend a lot of time outside.
Are there specific things genetically or otherwise whereby doctor and I might want to look?
So, yeah, there are genes for vitamin D or VDR genes that you can look on your report.
I don't even know who asked this question, but you can look on your genetic report and see if you have defects in your vitamin D receptor genes, your VDR genes.
And if that is the case, you're going to have a more difficult time keeping your vitamin D levels up, and you're going to have to supplement higher doses.
There's some people that just have a hard time absorbing and keeping vitamin D, and they just have to supplement a high doses.
So, that might be you.
What are some other possibilities that vitamin D issues when you're taking vitamin D?
Well, here it goes, it kind of goes back to, should I take things with a fat?
Vitamin D is a fat, soluble vitamin, taking it with fatty foods can, may actually improve the absorption of it.
So, you can try that, take your vitamin D with fatty foods, see if that increases your vitamin D levels.
Make sure you're getting a measured on a regular basis so you know what's going on, too.
That might be the thing.
So, and those are the, that's the main things that I would think of with vitamin D and not getting your vitamin D levels up.
We also see low vitamin D with autoimmune patients, real common.
So, check it if you have an autoimmune condition, would be a wise thing to do.
That would be running the Syrex Array 5 and Array 7x.
Syrex Array 5 and Array 7x.
That would be another thing to look at.
If you have not done a complete wellness panel, that will measure thyroid antibodies.
If you have self antibodies, AKA an autoimmune disorder, that tends to gobble up vitamin D levels as well.
Vitamin D is an immune regulatory agent, it's not an immune stimulant.
So, when it's needed for regulation of immune system in an autoimmune patient,
when they get these fluctuations of this immune attack on cells, it could gobble up their vitamin D levels.
So, almost all autoimmune patients, especially ones that don't know that they're autoimmune and we test that.
They'll have fairly low vitamin D levels, even if they're taking vitamin D.
So, I would investigate that as well.
I have been doing the carnivore diet.
There are many testimonials that have helped it cost you more than as well as cancer for five weeks.
I've done well on it and have no intestinal or other symptoms while on it.
Last week, for about four days, before the diarrhea.
So, this person asked another question that they had diarrhea.
I ate cheese, I've had no dairy for about a year before this.
My carol thinks that diarrhea is just my gallbladder overreacting to all the fat with the additional cheese.
And it will subside by stock cheese on Sunday.
I've also had three rounds of contrudeau with my keyboard.
The last contrudeau was early in November.
Could the tan diarrhea be a side of another autoimmune disease popping up like colitis or something else?
Could this happen long after the last dose?
Well, I'll answer the last question first.
Yes, it could happen long after the last dose.
Well, I should really say in the symptoms of it could show after the last dose.
Long after the last dose.
So, if you do have colitis, we have antibodies too.
So, colitis is just not an autoimmune disease, but it's a combination of colitis.
That could be still, that could have caused an autoimmune issue.
But, testing for antibodies would be really the thing to do.
However, I would look at, I don't know that I would completely agree with your other doctor
that the diarrhea is your gallbladder overacting, because by your gallbladder overreacting,
that's not going to really give you diarrhea for several days.
Your gallbladder is contracted, it's squirting out bile into the wadden,
which is going to digest fat more.
So, when you eat fatty food like dairy,
your bile is going to be secreted from the gallbladder in greater amounts,
and it will help break down the dairy.
But that isn't going to cause diarrhea.
However, if you have antibodies, if you have antibodies in different foods,
I could have casecid antibodies.
Absolutely, you could get this reaction.
So, if you were contacting me and you were not a cancer patient,
you had no history of key true to use.
And you said you had diarrhea and it was tied to, maybe tied to dairy,
maybe tied to the carnivore diet that you were doing.
The first thing I would do is do a Syrex 3x, Syrex 4 and Syrex 10 on you.
Those are rates.
So, that would look for antibodies to food.
So, in a inflammatory process going on in your gut,
you want to dig into figure out why.
Now, if you're like, hey, I don't have the money to do those tests,
well, then you could do a food elimination.
I'm not sure I wouldn't, I don't know how much cheese you ate,
or it's just a little cheat on your diet.
But having cancer, you want to stay away from cheese for sure.
So, you want to stay away from dairy for sure.
Going out of food elimination diet would be another thing to do.
Like I said, just going off to see if it clears up.
See if it calms down.
If it does calm down, you can kind of say, maybe that's it.
Maybe I have antibodies to KC.
Certainly going on to keep true to ramps up your immune response,
and you're going to be more prone to develop a lot of immune disease.
But you're also more prone to create antibodies against foods that you're eating too.
So, that's a possibility.
So, only one way to check that is to do a,
a antivine test, which would be a Syrex array.
Three X.
All right, four.
All right, two.
Okay.
I had high herbal cystic 15.8.
It went on methyl V12.
It came down by a point.
And then kind of plateaued.
Integrative doctor, I am working with, but be on.
A two week low.
Methiety diet.
Expecting this to drop by.
Holosis see further.
Instead it went up three points.
So I'm back to taking the methyl V12.
So I assume that it's low.
Methiety diet.
You stopped the methyl V12.
Since limiting the meat temporarily.
Didn't bring down my wholeocysteine.
What do you think is the best approach?
So, homocysteine is an end product of the methiety cycle.
Methiety.
It's called the methiety cycle.
Because methiety was discovered as a participant of that cycle.
So that doesn't just do methiety.
So, um, folate pathway breaks down.
Um, uh, different things down in the methyl tetrahedral folate.
Goes into the methiety cycle.
B12 is recycled through the MTR, the MTRR gene.
It goes up to the finite and circles around to homocysteine.
And then it goes through the cysteine cycle.
So having excess homocysteine.
The first thing you think of is you need more methyl groups to help support that loop.
So, obviously going on methyl groups for you did the trick.
It brought it down into normal levels.
So I would just stay on methyl groups.
And I don't think you have to necessarily worry about it.
About it plateau.
You may have some issues back up in through the cysteine cycle too.
So we might have to schedule a call with me.
I might have to take another look at your genetics and look at the cysteine pathway.
To see if there's a blockage there that might be one of the issues as well.
My homocysteine is around nine.
Can I take B12 B6 folate and trivethyl glycine or without the TMG?
Yeah.
I mean, you can do anything you want to do.
So, you know, this might need a specific visit with me.
I have to look at what I already have you on.
We're into your genetics as well.
And your lab work as well.
So it's hard to just, I don't, I don't, we're trying to.
To be as specific to you as possible to, with some of these questions,
but it can be difficult when I.
Answer it as a loop without getting into exactly your specifics.
So apologize for that.
Thanks for clarifying the more cola art.
I mean, is they write these articles not for specific types of disease?
Like cancer?
It drives me nuts.
I would agree.
So it's just like with anything, you just got to be careful of the weighty.
Everything with you.
I mean, I think everybody's different, first of all.
And I think there's some people that would do great on a low fat diet like that for a period of time.
And I think there's a lot of people that do great on NAD supplements.
Well, yeah, I can tell you half a dozen people that reacted horribly to NAD supplements, not cancer patients.
That got how hard computations and all sorts of problems.
So everybody's different.
That's the thing to remember.
So we got to be careful not to speak dog manically in anything that we do.
But when you are reading health things, there's a lot of information out there.
And I have people that send me Instagram videos and Facebook videos.
People that are, quote unquote, at your paths or natural functional medicine doctors that make claims that are just.
That are just are wrong for everybody.
And some are right, but they're not right for cancer patients or some are right.
But they're not right for everybody.
But they use such dogmatic language.
Okay, somebody, somebody made a video like, is copper bad for you?
That's nonsense.
And he went off on this whole thing about copper is good for you.
And we need copper blah blah blah blah blah.
Well, he's just completely wrong.
You know, copper toxicity is a huge issue.
Since we put copper pipes in our homes, since we, you know, for many centuries, use copper pans for cooking.
Copper toxicity is very common.
And it can be a cause for cancer because it leads to zinc deficiency or we should say a relative zinc deficiency.
A lot of people have ill health because they have a copper overload.
And that is an issue.
So, and some people just don't know what they're talking about.
And some people are do know what they're talking about, but it doesn't relate to cancer.
And some people do know what they're talking about, but then they make it so dogmatic.
Like everybody should do this, which standards are not true.
Not everybody should do anything.
So, very few things.
So, just be, be aware of those things.
Clear talks does have an ADHD.
Yes, I know.
But when we test you for it, that's why I said, we have some people on glutathione.
So, that should work.
So, should someone high homocyste not take an ADHD?
I would say no.
So, an ADHD functions way down the system pathway.
So, it helps recycle glutathione.
And that's that's really why someone would take an ADHD.
So, in recycling glutathione can help detoxify a cell with if someone is exposed to.
Specific toxins, especially what that is was created for was for the vaccine.
And it works well with glyphosate to help detox glyphosate.
And it helps work with detoxed.
So, Michael toxins.
So, no, no, I don't think that you have to limit that.
And it's a smaller amount.
You're not taking high doses of ADHD.
The low fat he recommends is not really low.
Just low comparison to keto.
He said keep that around 30% which is higher than that you were thinking.
The article he clarified the simple versus complex carbs and people with typical gut microbes.
From standard American diet, the complex carbs are not the digested well and create endotoxins.
So, start with simple carbs like fruit juices and then you get really healthy microbes.
Switch to the complex carbs.
So, I'm talking about still plenty of healthy fat.
Plus some complex carbs mostly vegetables or berries.
Still a bit unclear of your feelings about trying to boost NAD.
Vital cordial health does high homocysteine come into play with this extra B.
Though the extra B is actually going to lower homocysteine levels.
So, the NAD again, just taking, you know, boosting too much NAD on a constant basis again.
Does help mitochondrial health in the, in, in an effect.
So, let's make sure we, not really increasing mitochondrial health.
You're just giving the might, so the mitochondria is where you produce glutathione.
So, you're just giving building blocks for glutathione in the mitochondria.
You're not really, you know, they're not mitochondria are getting healthier because you're doing that.
Um, so, but you just got to be careful in keeping if cancer cells utilize that.
It's helping keep cancer cells alive.
So, that's where we do it a rotational type guy.
It can be beneficial, not stayed on.
Some one specific thing, unless we test you for it.
That's why getting cheek swab tests on a regular basis.
Then we can tweak things and see what works for you.
That's why, you know, even I don't try not to take a dogmatic approach, even though sometimes I speak that way and I apologize.
But I'm trying to, to do an individual approach for everyone as best as we can.
Searching NADH, NAD plus 80, ATP mitochondria.
I would search glutathione maybe.
How about how long term the type of research in boosting cortisol in order to get you the sugar you need?
First of all, when you talk about cortisol and, you know, and looking at cortisol level, that he that he was talking about too.
Well, they fail to say about your question is I think you should measure things.
So if you can measure things, you can better.
You know, you can better change things.
So getting a cortisol test done.
And if you, if you have breast cancer, I recommend to do the.
Dutch test, the Dutch complete has the cortisol test in it as well.
So if you, if you don't have breast cancer, you don't have any hormonal driven cancer.
Even with pulmonary cancer or anything like that, but let's say you're colon cancer.
And you're not concerned about your horrible levels.
And you just want to look at cortisol levels.
You could do the adrenal stress profile.
It's just a salivary test that is sent to you.
ZRT lab.
You measure it in four different times during the day.
It's the same exact thing you do within the Dutch test.
You're not doing the whole.
And so it's a little bit less expensive.
But measure cortisol levels.
So do the adrenal stress profile.
You can measure cortisol levels and see if we need to make any changes with that or at all.
It's always best to look at that.
So yes.
And to answer that question, stop.
I go back on that method each.
Would the Syrex test be something my GP could do though?
So your GP, unless they're a functional medicine doctor, that understands these things.
They don't even know if this stuff is so.
No.
Can't.
Or similar test by a different aim and therefore possibly covered by insurance.
No.
That's not out there.
So.
I apologize, but it just it isn't.
To clean the inside of the arteries, which enzyme should be used?
Nanokytos, kinase or lumbarokytase or both.
I'd use both.
So the nano kinase and the lumbarokytase can be good for that.
Do you recommend repeating Dutch test periodically?
Absolutely.
Because.
Well, your cortisol level is going to change.
And I will say this, if you're going to do a cortisol test either through the Dutch test or the adrenal stress profile, you really have to do it on a day that's a normal day.
Because if your normal is fairly in your mind, fairly stress free, but then you had a super stressful day.
And it's it's going to show on the and then on that day, you do the adrenal stress profiles.
It's it's not going to be a real test.
You want to do it on what you would consider your normal day.
It might be very stressful, but if that's if you're under a lot of stress all the time, you want to know what it what your cortisol holes are.
And then average, you know, time.
So if if if it was just a day full of stress and you run it, then it's you lose the value of it.
So you lose them out because your quarter of the levels are going to go up and down.
You know, depending on your stress levels, you know, your cortisol is released by your adrenal glands.
It functions on many different levels and one of the levels is to break down glycogen stores.
For how long should the enzymes be used?
So are you you're talking about the lumbarol kinase and the nano kinase?
Well, if you're used, if you're doing it just to help you're a healthy to do is a good job and try to clean up your your arteries and as best you can, you use them on a regular basis.
And again, just like anything else or something or always pulsating supplements and using for three months and go off them for a month to go back on them or use them several days a week, something like that.
Try to see if I should adjust my diet.
I have put on 30 pounds in the last eight months.
I haven't changed my diet.
Whole food, no sugar, no dairy.
Also, I know gluten or my workouts four to five times a week.
I know my four bones are low.
And you said that is good due to heavy breast cancer, which should I do or more replacement or adjust my diet suggestions.
Should I go do fasting?
I did start the heart and soil supplement.
I emailed you about maybe see if this helps.
Yeah, so this is where, you know, you go, okay, what am I doing wrong?
I put on 30 pounds in the last eight months. I haven't changed a thing.
This is where is, you know, measure read.
I don't remember Jessica if we did a cortisol panel on you or not.
That's where, you know, looking at that might be the right thing to look at for you and see how we can get that cortisol levels down.
Maybe doing going with adaptogenic herbs or something like that.
Very unique.
I don't know without getting very specific with you.
How long after bread is on 14 day, will your sugar start to lower and center during the day with hardly any carbs.
My sugar is still registered at 127.
Yeah, that's a hard answer because out of get is different with everybody.
Pride is older and drop any drug can affect everybody differently.
I've had people that were on predisone for something and it just took forever to get their glucose back in order.
So give yourself some time. This is only been two weeks.
One of the things that you could think of doing to try to help with your blood sugar levels is to do some weight buried exercises like weight lifting.
And glucose is going to be attracted to muscle that is contracting.
So not talking about aerobic exercises in this in a stance of going out ruddy or something like that but get some 10, 15, 20, 25 pound weights depending on how bulky you are.
And do some weight just some curls some weight lifting curls and deep beds squats with the weights or something like that that may help.
So get your muscles burning that glucose up so it's not feeding any kids or cells.
But Saturday out of the blue began tearing bubbly water e-files valid tools and it continues what this be from.
So you're the one that asked the question about then you started that on Saturday.
And you a cheese.
So I think we kind of get that question again.
Hopefully you listen to my answer that there's some sort of inflammation going on. There's some sort of reaction going on to be a reaction to food could be a reaction to be just an inflammatory process going on and you're got.
Just don't have a magic ball to answer that. But those are the things you'd have to run some tests to see.
If anything we can get out of this call today is you're going to try to measure things. So try to measure things without making.
So, you know, getting a wrong ideas. Yes, if you can't afford to do tests then you can measure it by trying to make some changes like in a diet elimination diet to see if anything else changes.
Right back to this question about game 30 pounds to is there something that's causing inflammation it could be.
You know, something in your diet that even though you have a great diet.
Even though you have a great diet.
It doesn't mean that you that you're not eating something that is highly inflammatory and causing you to gain weight.
For instance, you know, about a gluten free diet. So I only eat gluten free flour. Well, maybe what's what's maybe tapioca starch.
Antibodies through the roof, first and happy a quick start. So every time you eat that you're causing this huge inflammation of the gut. You're not getting.
You know, good absorption of nutrients.
And you might absorb macro nutrients. You're just gaining weight causing inflammation of the brain. It's shutting down a whole bunch of different things.
You have to measure things so running a Syrex array 10 might be an order for you to see if it's something dietary that is causing inflammation.
Remember anything inflammation the gut is going to cause inflammation the brain it's going to affect to a chance to affect hormones it's going to affect a whole bunch of different things.
So, you know, I'm not against like, you know, trying to do some different things. If that's what you can do. But if you can measure things, it's much better.
It's not just so we have high cortisol levels. We could have low cortisol levels.
Now, tell you how many people we've done on a adrenal stress profile.
And it's not that they have high cortisol levels. It's that they have no cortisol. I mean, it's literally a flatline.
Because their adrenals are completely shocked. So we're going to do things to decrease cortisol levels. You're actually entering your body.
So, you know, if you can measure things, you're going to be better off.
So, we can't measure everything. But the thing is that you can measure. We're going to be better off just like, okay, high homocyste. So we go on this is a lower homocyste.
And whoever asked that question could rate thing you're going through a process of I, I used that will be 12 at lower to this point.
And now it's just stubborn. It's staying there. Well, maybe we, maybe we might need higher concentration. Maybe we don't need to look at some other things. So I always try to do that.
I guess he and I had Hashimoto's from the key trutus. It's about October. Possibly. So, but did you ever measure cyroglobulin antibodies or TPO antibodies prior to that? I don't know.
I tried to heal it by using spy troflin PMG and I order all, okay, wrong thing to do. I order all you do not take iodine.
If you have primary cycle, not right isn't. Or if you have Hashimoto's, we'd ever use iodine. Please go back. I gave everybody permission to get on the autoimmune course. Go on the autoimmune course.
So the last module on autoimmune course. It's all about Hashimoto's. Please watch the videos on that. You know, colleges told me core stories about that going on.
By Roy on hormone replacement. I really do not want to be on a bed.
Well, I don't know what your T3 and T4 levels are. So, if you want to send me those labs and.
And it's got a little appointment we can pull over those. Do not take iodine. What do you have primary hypothyroidism or Hashimoto's.
So, all right. We are going to call it a night. Thanks for being on and good questions today. All right. Have a great week. See you next week. Bye bye.